the entire premise of our Republic rests  on an informed citizenry you can't have  freedom without knowledge and education  of what's going on and that's what the  journalists job is we have a very big  ambitious core curriculum everyone here  gets fundamentally educated the first  word that comes to mind when I think  about Hillsdale is that the students  they're very serious very serious about  learning they come with you know great  questions I would much rather hire  somebody who knows something and teach  them the craft then find someone who's  only learned the craft but doesn't know  it we work very hard to help our  students plan jobs on graduation in fact  everybody who minors in journalism who  wants a job in journalism pretty much  gets  [Music]